ces images sont filmées et commentées
par le maire de Kiev vitalité
le pont est endommagé
je vois des débris ici des fragments de
missiles du verre brisé partout
mais je suis convaincu que nous allons
tout reconstruire
après les frappes russes il inspecte les
dégâts sur cette passerelle au cœur de
la capitale
comment ça va tout va bien
vous avez tout vérifié
oui est-ce qu'on peut nettoyer ici
oui s'il vous plaît hier une pluie de
missiles s'est abattue sur des villes
habituellement épargnées par l'armée
russe la capitale mais aussi vif soumis
gitomir ou encore ni pro des frappes
menées selon qui a faim désespoir de
cause face à la contre-offensive
ukrainienne
dans la soirée volo dix meilleurs Hélène
ski tente de remonter le moral des
troupes
nous allons reconstruire toutes les
infrastructures qui ont été endommagées
par l'attaque des terroristes russes ce
n'est qu'une question de temps même
résistance dans l'Est dans l'un des
territoires annexés illégalement par
Moscou à Donetsk les soldats Ukrainiens
tirent
et continue de reprendre du terrain
ils ne peuvent rien faire contre nos
forces armées c'est pourquoi ils
essaient d'influencer notre population
civile en frappant des villes qui sont
derrière nous
en début de semaine Vladimir Poutine
avait promis des répliques sévères en
cas de nouvelles attaques ukrainiennes
de jour après la destruction partielle
du pont de Crimée